why is your holiday outfit what they
give dogs after they get groomed okay
well Annie what does this tag say it
says oh my God she's making me it says
are a dog a doggy go that's cuz I
couldn't find a Christmas outfit today
and I'm wearing my dog scarf I was like
you this is how codependent this [__]
she even shares clothes with her dog
well no cuz I was like I got the memo or
the reminder yesterday to be like hey
it's a Christmas themed episode I'm like
oh [__] so I was like let's go full um
Christmas cowgirl but I didn't have the
scarf so I ripped this off my dog's neck
we all look like we're at extremely
different holiday parties wait but can I
say that I am also um Western Christmas
no oh oh my god wow
wow what is with I'm hybrid this show is
sponsored by better help in the season
of giving give yourself what you need
with betterhelp visit betterhelp.com TR
Tuesday today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com Tuesday if you go to getquip.com
sltr Tuesday right now you'll get 20%
off any electric toothbrush or mint and
gum dispenser plus listeners of the show
will get an exclusive 20% off discount
on the Chantel Martin collection bundle
it's 20% off any electric toothbrush
mint and gum dispenser or the Chantel
Martin bundle at getquip.com TR Tuesday
spelled g
q.com TR Tuesday quip the good habits
company slugs happy holidays I have just
a few more dates left on my tour January
7th is my rescheduled show in San Jose
January 18th I'll be in Portland and
just announced January 26 I'll be in
Seattle get tickets at eston ice.com I
cannot wait to share this material with
you guys I'll see you there happy
Christmas happy New Year happy all those
things I am so excited this Thursday I
am at the comedy store with another
annwood and Friends December 21st I have
Johnny
pton um Josh Potter and Bobby Lee it's
going to be so fun then you can see me
in January I'm going to Edmonton um
Alberta I'm going to Jacksonville
Florida January 19th and 20th I'm G to
be again in annwood at another annwood
at the comedy store then I'll be in
Denver Colorado in February and in
Vancouver and in March I'll be in
Washington DC I adding so many more
shows so go to Annie letter.com shows to
see them I love love performing for you
I love meeting you guys I can't
wait I would never have considered
Western Christmas well your what is
yours mine is Pajama holiday that's how
we do it in my family well this is like
opening presents yeah this is like
trying to get knocked up to match Esther
my my family is so lazy every year is um
pajama do you guys all have matching
pajamas no we just come in pajamas it
doesn't even need to be Christmas themed
pajamas it's just pajamas that always
teases is my mom cuz she just is
constantly in pajamas when she's walking
around the house she's like there she
goes the boy in the stripe
pajamas she wears like the old school
ones with the actual like stripes down
like the very you know what I mean my
mom and dad both wear night gowns okay
wow okay both them wear night gowns so
if we were to do a Christmas in our
pajamas I'm seeing my dad's dick and
balls an old man in a night gown rules
but he wears like he has a Coca-Cola one
and then there and it comes with like a
hat but he doesn't wear the hat like my
dad is night gown that's a your dad is a
Christmas decoration like my dad's a
Christmas decoration should have an old
man and he has the jingle balls wait now
my dad used to wear this thing not for
Christmas but every day around the house
this thing called a I think they're
called gabas or gelas but my dad's
family um he spent a good amount of time
in Egypt so it's like you know just a
one long dark like a oh no like a like a
long sleeved a Garb yeah um and that's
just what he was he like looked like a
wizard all year long around the house
was he wearing a pointy hat he was my
yeah and my mom is like so annoying with
everything like she's like if you get
her a night count it has to be like 100%
cotton there can't be like any other
thing and it's so you're like G she's
always got like a Tweety Bird or
something cuz it's like the ones that
come as 100% cotton wait why though
what's like the she's just everything
itches her everything B her she's a
little bit like someone I know well I
was going to say 100% cotton is like the
better version but polyester does feel
like it's softer do you know what she
does wear is her nighton which is
actually so cute is when we used to hang
out with Whitney all the time over the
pandemic and Whitney made the Whitney
camp shirts oh yeah she wears like an
oversized Whitney camp shirt which is my
mom wears a ton of Whitney merch too our
moms don't like us they like they're
using us to get to Whitney like everyone
else in our lives by the way my mom
wears all of your merch so a and it wait
so we had like a little checkin Kila um
let me see um I feel anxious and I don't
know why fighting someone why your dog
scar I'm channeling oh my God she's like
Benji she's gonna start turning into the
dog the movie Benji um I um I'm really
proud of you that you noticed that this
was my dog scarf actually no I feel
anxious you know like those days where
you are just sweating and maybe your
body's operating at a level like that's
not connecting to any like thoughts in
your head so I came here I was driving
here and I was sweating and I didn't is
it weird when you feel yeah you feel
anxiety and then you have to do like a
scan of your life I usually I'm on adro
when that happens scan of your I go like
you know seriously like you're like I'm
feeling anxious is did I do something
and then I'm like oh I took and I think
it's because I had a nocturnal panic
attack last night and I'm always like is
this a nocturnal panic attack or is this
my heart condition kicking off again so
which gives you the panic attack and
then it spirals into a panic attack and
I was alone and I haven't been in the ER
in over a year which I'm really proud of
you went no no I didn't I like sat down
I calm myself down I didn't know where I
was I was like sweating it was just it's
a scary thing and I think that's why I'm
anxious today but I'm hopeful that the
day will turn around okay just heads up
I'm great in emergency rooms and I'm up
all night I would go with you but her
point is that she hasn't gone in a year
and she doesn't want to go I'm she needs
someone to go yeah like I'm holding my
my cuz I have um I carry a tenolol it's
the beta blocker in case um and I'll do
all the things like I'll put ice on my
face and do all the things but I sit
there and I'm like at what point is my
heart rate going to go down or is it
just going to speed up and you're always
like should I wake Jules up should I
sound the alarm and then finally it
settled back and I was able to go back
to sleep but those nights are not easy
for me those are my feelings today
Stella do you have any like
emergency like panic attack 911 like for
me it would be like a if I'm having like
something Ser like for example when I
was like having weed if I took too much
half a Xanax everything's fine do you
have like some kind of emergency tablet
for that or is that like a beta blocker
for you um but the beta blocker is
basically to bring down because I have
an arhythmia so it just takes down my
heart rate because it'll shoot up to 200
is it like propanalol uh similar yeah
propanalol is a beta blocker too learned
about those in acting class because like
our acting teacher would say if you get
nervous for auditions take a beta
blocker you will not and it literally
Works how are you guys feeling I'm
feeling pretty good I have my show at
the comedy store tonight so I'm excited
about that it's headlining post
pregnancy being public is there's still
like a little pieces pieces of the
puzzle that I'm figuring out orderwise
so I kind of have to work on that this
afternoon um but I'm overall excited
like I have some new material I'm like
just excited to share I think that's
like it for how I'm feeling today do you
feel as though like your creative juices
are flowing more now that you're
pregnant yeah and I think it I don't
know if it is because I'm pregnant or if
it's because the 3 months I spent
completely useless miserable sick first
trimester in bed shut out from the world
being out of that slowly I'm like let's
go like I just feel like a hunger for
every little element of life I'm like oh
my God I want to like just take a daily
walk just like I just am so or catch up
with a friend like every little thing
like even when I'm coming here I'm like
oh something different something
exciting I I just really am and I don't
know hopefully that will last or
probably everything is going to
change there's no predicting what will
happen but I know it's weird that you
have to it's almost like topical jokes
that you're doing because you're going
to not be pregnant at some point oh for
that well yeah I didn't even think about
that but I meant everything's going to
change like oh I hope I keep this
enthusiasm but like in 3 months the
pregnancy might suck again and then in 3
months after that I'm going to have a
baby and who knows I'll might just be
only enthusiastic about my baby but yeah
no I definitely I'm excited about the
pregnancy material though you're going
to have so much like stuff too after the
baby's born too you know I didn't even
think that it the I never even
considered in this moment that I
wouldn't be pregnant one day like you're
taking a day by day yes you're in the
moment yeah um Annie how about how are
you today I'm doing good I got a spray
tan I drove two hours to get a spray tan
last night where why I go because my
girl was busy she was you know I was in
between Selena Gomez and Miley Cyrus so
I had to get there and um it's no big
deal but I do have hyperhydrosis so the
armpits always White we're going to go
and see Dr Cohen and then my spray Tan's
going to rule but I did yoga this
morning and they were like let's do
everything against the wall and so I was
doing like these back poses against the
wall and I left like all the spray tan
just like the form of my back just with
my sports bra not there is just on my
the wall forever I forgot to clean it my
bad but yeah no I woke up I've been
listening to a new meditation that's
like really makes me like buzz in the
morning so it's been like keeping me
really high Vibes and then I went to a
really cool yoga class like I the place
that I go to which I will never mention
they're very cool it's like a different
it's weird yoga it's like every class is
really different so it's like fun I get
out of my head I can't like expect
what's going to happen I don't know I
just feel really excited about that I
woke up at 700 to find this I'm just in
awe of how many costumes you have but
how every time we have a theme you find
it yeah I well I got up early for it CU
I was like otherwise I was just going to
wear like red pants no
offense but I just like I don't know
I've always kept this because I know
it's going to be Christmas again you're
going to know I really feel like [__]
about myself when I stop wearing this is
it from the holiday last year I saw no
it's from Hawaii oh yeah I've do it
every year wait I one second sorry I
think your
nipple actual nipple yeah I'm showing my
chicken cutlets you know I show my dents
I show my tracks one of my biggest
traumas in my life is my chicken cutlet
falling out from underneath my bra at a
on a dance floor and then my friend
picking it up and being like you're
titties girl you're titties okay I would
100% be that friend and to me that would
be one of my favorite memories like when
I was a go- go dancer I used to wear
them and I would be sweating and they
would like slide up and people would be
like your titty thing showing people
like your chicken cutlet and they all
thought I was transgender or a drag
queen because there was one drag queen
that danced with me and they would like
and she would duct tape her well he she
went by he but duct tape and so people
like do you have duct tape the shoulders
the mustache The Voice how are we all
feeling about our holiday plans like
what are we doing what are we excited
about have you decorated yet I
personally don't dabble in decorating I
thought you were going to go full force
this Christmas this is her full
force for I bought these holiday themed
pajama pants at Old Navy what are you
about I have a question why did you pick
the
trailers these were the only ones they
had left in my size for maternity but
then they looked I like patterned like
really obvious by maternity do you mean
kid section are still very tiny oh my
God it's the teen pregnancy section teen
maternity maity but like okay no I
haven't decorated but I do think once we
have a kid like that's when I'm going to
really invest in getting them to do it
for you yeah in like going full like I
remember Trisha P us like on in October
1st she's like we're doing Halloween
themed stuff every day I was like Dave
that's going to be us you don't
understand but I'm really excited for my
holiday plans cuz I'm doing a long trip
home and how long is long like 10 days
do you and Dave always spend Christmas
together not always no but he's coming
with me for part of the trip and then my
childhood best friend will be there and
we're going to go to the new cosmics um
in Bowling Brook
Illinois and I'm just like excited to I
hope it snows I want to listen to
Christmas music I want to go shopping
after Christmas at for sales like at the
mall I just want to be like lowkey basic
as as basic as I can be and I'm like
looking forward to that a lot yeah it's
feels like high scho it's not sad at all
that sounds so cozy and delici I need it
no it's good you're about to have a very
different wait tell me about your guys
holiday plans I've already decorated the
exterior of my home but not like my
sister does like my sister goes like
full like Clark roswald right like she
is with all the lights and all the
reindeers and flatable she does all of
that I kept it Chic this year I just
have some um lights hanging outside my
window I have a wreath and then I didn't
want to get the tree yet cuz I felt like
it was going to dry out by Christmas and
give me allergies so I'm getting the
tree tomorrow and um I'm going to be
spending it with my family we do it
Filipino style we order Filipino food we
play parlor games you order so no
there's no cooking some cooking it's
half and half but things like crispy Po
and stuff like it's they're harder to
cook so we just order it and then I
don't quite know what that is but I want
it it's a deep fried uh it's pork you
eat pork mm okay
settle if if you Google crispy po I feel
like Annie might come I want it and um
eser squeeze my fake nipple so it's in
La your Christmas uh yeah um I'm going
to spend half of it or right before
Christmas I'm going to be in Hawaii with
my friends and loved ones and then I
come back right before Christmas to hang
out with my friends and loved ones here
oh cute and um that's crispy PA Annie
you had it at my party I was eating fla
[__] I was eating fla Kile had a fla
this big no it was really this big it
was literally this big it was amazing
yeah did you make that fla no no no some
um it was my friend's coworker it was
just a random lady it wasn't even from a
shop she just like let's make the
biggest fla in the world I've ever seen
and do you do Christmas Eve or Christmas
Day Christmas Eve Christmas Eve same
yeah so when you were little did you
guys do at night right yeah yeah we used
to do Christmas Eve was one present you
get one present from the family and then
you would we would all sleep together in
the room we'd sleep in my older brother
Timmy's room it was so exciting wait all
the kids only or the parents you're so
funny parents
know like real slumber party with
everyone like seven people in a small
bedroom is like a dream well we woke up
to Timmy lived in the third on the third
floor so we would think we could hear
Santa on the roof so we would go up
there and we it was so hard to go to
sleep and my brother had this like
little alarm clock he would set for
seven yeah I'll never forget that alarm
clock and we would like sleep on the
floor all three of us and we would like
the minute we woke up we would just like
Timmy would go check first he would run
down but and then Santa would leave like
a trail of Hershey Kisses all the way up
the stairs all the way down to the tree
oh swi all different kinds all different
kinds all different kinds and but I will
say how did they hurt when you stepped
on them like actual slicing point and
you would run downstairs and then so we
had our one present the night before and
then we would go down and we would get
our presents and it was there were bikes
we were so spoy we were spoy spoy spoy
that's how Todd's mom says it one of my
favorite naughty memories is like me and
my sister when when everything was quiet
by the tree at my grandparents house CU
we did every Christmas in Minnesota we
would my sister was like okay so you
know how I'm we're kind of like slobs
right like rip through things it's
really hard just a hard this isn't what
I wanted hard lifestyle right so but my
sister much like my mom they're like
perfectionists they can do any little
meticulous thing so my sister and I
would go to the tree before Christmas
Eve when it's quiet and my sister would
use her perfectionist skills and open
the gifts and we would see what was in
there and I was always like yes she's so
useful and that I'm like I find myself
like thinking about that I'm like that
was fun sister B even was naughty my old
homeschooled like super Christian
neighbors they were hoarders and they
loved R Rush limbo um they would reuse
all the wrapping paper so to open the
wrapping paper they would take a um
butter knife and very carefully slice
everything open and fold the paper up to
use again that's kind of like green
that's kind of not Republican that's
very like my mom she opens things so she
doesn't tear the paper so she saves it
for another time my sister my mom did
that too wait but you didn't tell us
what are your Christmas plans this year
Christmas plans they're kind of still up
in the air because I'm going to go see
my nieces so my older brother and the
boys are going to Disney On Ice which
I'm actually live it about because I
feel like I'm more fun than Disney on
Ice not to sound narcissistic but on but
have you been to Disney On Ice no I'm
not a Disney but it's pretty great we
used to do that when I was little we got
some bootle version in the
I don't think we got the real one but it
was like one of my core memories you
know what my one sister well my one
sister why are only the boys going to
Disney On Ice because it's their family
his like my sister-in-law decided my
brother's like they're not going to like
it but maybe they will but so they're
doing that on the 26 so now that kind of
[__] blocks us all being in Boston
together so now I'm like okay we can do
Todd's family for Christmas we do a a
secret santa anyway and I'm very excited
about who I get and I can't give away
any hints cuz they might watch the show
you're getting spyed we're like so we'll
do Secret Santa with them and then we'll
drive up to Boston and see my niece's
but I got my niece the best present it's
like exactly what she wants she wants
the Stanley Cup that that one of
survived all the kids want it that's
like the Jen I I have the list of all
the hottest genen Z gifts and that's one
it's so cute so she wants it really bad
so then I got her like the one that sold
out like I searched everywhere like this
floresent pink one and I got a small one
for her and a big one for me so it's
like we have matching cute and then I'm
getting stickers of like her cat and
pictures of us together so she can stick
them on but she wants she's like I don't
want like the pink shiny one and that's
the one I got her and I spent like over
$200 it's like you but I was like she's
like I want she go like eBay or
something eBay I just searched I'm like
nothing nothing will stop me to get what
my girl wants but then she's like I
don't want that one she's like I want
the white one and I went you're not
going to be basic I went to her I go I
know you can't the white I want I know
what's cool Auntie knows what's cool I'm
cooler than any of your friends and
anyone you know and you know that and so
she's going to freak out and I think
that we have the matching ones and then
I have to get something for my baby
niece it's class I have a couple
specific kid Christmas questions that I
would like to ask you okay now that you
have a kid will you be doing Christmas
photos and sending them like the
Kardashians do okay so a long time ago
when Dave and I were early in our
relationship he once casually said that
if we ever have
kids we're not allowed to have Christmas
or Hanukkah now she's marrying the
gringe
he why I think it was a conversation
that like me and a couple friends were
having about like Christmas or Hanukkah
and Dave is just he has these phases you
know these modes like for example one
year he asked for me to get this book
for him it's called it's better to have
never been born like he's just kind of a
contr giving that to the kid the baby
book I like the idea of intuitive
parenting for my I would say for myself
it's like whatever like what can you
plan feels right at that time and I
think Dave has since gone back on his
rule of no holidays I mean he's going to
have to didn't you say you want your kid
to be goth it's kind of goth to have no
holidays well goth like in appearance I
like but H but light I just really want
her to have dark hair that's all I
really meant by that and we will hna die
that [__] okay so the next question that
we have for you Ester is the Santa Claus
if you say you do celebrate Christmas
with your child how are you you going to
handle are you going to lie to your kid
about Santa Claus we've talked about
this on the show before which you guys I
think we all I just you both disagree
with me I think this is like a big point
but has your mind changed um since no
I'm not lying to my child and making up
a story you're going to ruin their
childhood it's here's what it will be
fomo for life Santa is a make believe
story that we play pretend is happening
it's not real it's just we're going to
have play pretend tell tell the story
Santa's coming exciting I'm pulling her
aside and going your mom's lying Santa's
real she's tricking you she's being a
weirdo about it I don't know why yeah
the aunties will [__] it up for you
because because it's okay so with my I'm
gonna I'm gonna give like a trigger
warning to my sister-in-law so she
doesn't listen to this in front of my
niece that I don't think she does anyway
because I say curse words but but my
niece is 11 okay okay she put on lip
gloss to meet Santa and this year
they're like we have to like I was over
there when she was nine when she was
nine we were like I was there the night
we were like going to tell her that
Santa's not real but she was so like
excited about him that we're like no and
then she put on lip gloss she asked him
for her cell phone so I think she might
know but it's like what a manipulation
to be like to pretend you still know but
they were like sat down and they were
going to tell her and then she was so
excited about it that they just were
like abort abort abort let her have her
fun as long as she can I think for me um
I liked writing letters it was the first
time that I knew I could express myself
on on paper um and ask for reflect on
the year before so it was like this is
what happened in my year in a very
childish way of course this is what I'm
looking forward to these are the things
that I feel I deserve but it was a place
for my feelings and thoughts and my
wishes and dreams and then I would I
would seal it put it in North Pole and I
knew that it was sealed so I sent Kila I
just sent a list of things I didn't say
Dear Santa like L's L's maybe I said
Dear Santa give me these thank you so I
Carri that on to my adulthood I only
stopped a couple years ago it was like a
Dear Santa long letter but it was just a
year of reflection why would you stop
now um I you know now I just tell my
therapist did Esther finally tell you
Santa's not real she ruin Christmas for
you know until then I love that you did
that and I feel like that could still
happen in a Meek beli way yeah maybe
maybe you should write him some poetry
when I lied to my niece about it I feel
really bad like it feels really weird
wait but are kids shattered when they
find out find out because I was
shattered shattered you were shattered I
so shattered old were you I mean it's
cuz I figured it out on my own when I
was like six and it was like Christmas
is ruin like and everything's a lie you
know why you guys were shattered cuz
adults who you loved and trusted were
lying to you I agree you're an actress
they were playing it was a stage they
were playing they were acting yet that's
the version that I will do is we're
playing Santa I just I
look I think it's cool it's magical it's
not for me if your kid tells people
that's where the problem is yeah that's
true I'm not going to encourage that I'm
just going to say look so you're going
to make her be a liar no I'm going to
say look are you going to lie or is she
going to lie because you're ruining
people's Christmas if some of your
friends are stupid enough to believe
that Santa is real let's just let them
be I figured it out on my own but then
when I figured it out I didn't I loved
watching my parents because it was you
know I didn't have an easy childhood so
but this was like the time for ceasefire
where like everything this was the only
time like I will stop dying yeah he
stopped dying my mom was like kind to me
cuz the downside is Persona nrata were
then invited back into the family and
it's like why is my molester at
Christmas dinner you know what I mean
anyways dressed as Santa he is Santa um
but for me it was like I really
appreciated that my parents went above
and beyond and I'm like I already know
it's not real but there still creating
this thing for me and it was the one
time I truly felt like loved by them I'm
like oh they don't have to do this my
mom has beat me between January to
November and now we have December and
she's she wanted you to be red and green
for the holiday she just wanted you to
match yeah so I wasn't shattered I just
I think I wanted to carry on the fantasy
of it all because they were nice to me
over Christmas but again that still
would work in my scenario yeah yeah yeah
I I I'm starting to kind of side with
you a little bit but I do wonder I want
to see how it plays out and isn't it
crazy though like I'm feeling that same
experience that like as you right now
almost like oh my God the holidays it's
all about Nostalgia and so creating
those memories when you're young then
it's like every year you have this
little secret access code to Memories
Nostalgia I don't know like every
Christmas decoration it just puts you in
a good mood and so for me like it
doesn't have to be about religion it
doesn't even have to be about presence
it's just like oh this music and these
colors I mean the presents though
presents were great big when you were a
kid okay so the answer the verdict is
Esther um we're going to tell the kid
what age are you going to say hey Santa
is a make believe thing it's always
going to be make believe okay from the
moment they ask yeah even at like two
years old they don't do they have the
conceptual we'll get a book we'll read
the book and then we'll be like Let's
Pretend This is got it okay and we'll do
that for every book we'll pretend every
book is and we'll play I'm like
I'm going to get so into playing I'm
like very excited to
play We also we open presents on
Christmas Eve and then maybe it's like
oh these are the Santa like small gifts
on the morning we did I forgot too we
would go we would get our stockings go
up to our parents wake our parents up do
stockings in bed and then go down and
open our presents oh cute my mom would
make like eggs and bacon and if my
grandfather was there he would make slow
cooked bacon that was just bacon on low
for five hours smells the whole house up
you're so hungry like poppy are they
it's still cooking give me the [__]
bacon did you guys go to church that's
when we did Christmas Eve we went to
church this is what I was I'm going to
ask you you know the TW celebrating on a
24th like no buana and stuff is a very
like brown people thing to do like I
always thought like when waking up in
breakfast Christmas breakfast and
opening gifts was like what we
considered very a white tradition so
like I'm surprised that you guys
NOAB they're brown people they're
they're brown people SS I'm surprised
you guys do it on on the 24th I love
that is interesting it might be because
like we're not super religious so maybe
it's like the more religious people you
go to church D did you go to church on
like Easter too or just on no only on
Christmas Eve but that's cuz we were
always at my grandparents house and they
were churchgoers so we just like
pretended like we did that too but not
like midnight mass right no my friend
did I always wanted to do that and
sometimes that does sound like almost
sleepover Church yeah there is a feeling
that is there is a feeling midnight mass
is really special in that way like even
if you're not religious it's like you
see everyone's like up past midnight and
you're like wow why are we doing this
why are we here and you see your friends
you know and it's kind ofur is like fun
whether you're religious or
not it's so fun church have you well
Todd and I were doing that for ANW and
we just did one we just did we were
going to do Church reviews we just went
to Quaker Meeting and it was actually so
sad because everyone in the meeting's so
old and they were so excited to see like
young people cuz they're all going to
die out there's going to be no one left
to go to Quaker Meeting and then but we
were like oh we're just checking in
we're not going to be here again do you
want to go together yeah I'll go with
you I want to do like can we start
cathol have you gone to the crazy like
big churches the mega churches are so
fun they're like scary it's like you're
like they're beautiful they're like
palatial I see I'm not comfortable going
into a church as a stranger I I need to
be with a regular if I'm going in well
let's go just go with Annie well I
belong wherever I go when when I was
little I used to go to Catholic church
with Christina and I can't remember if
I've told you this but in health class
did you guys ever take home those
electronic babies I never got to do that
we they were too afraid we would
actually have kids they gave us like an
egg I got a D eser I did that I hated it
we had no we had uh flower we had a p of
flower oh my sister I think did that and
oh God watching kids get mad at each
other and kill their babies was the
funniest thing I've ever seen so we did
that and Christina like you was a twin
and so our teacher made her take two of
the babies which seems like she should
someone else UNF yeah so so Christina
had two and I remember we went went to
church and it was like dead of winter
and she had the two babies and they're
dolls so they weren't dressed they were
just like naked and their little things
and these all these old women came up to
us and were're like bless these poor
children like we scared everyone at the
church put that in a scried that's so
funny did they know they were fake
babies no of course not okay because I
used to carry around my friend and I
would carry around this blowup doll with
us we would go to like all these diners
Tiffany's Diner like we just thought it
was so funny we called her Judy we
brought her everywhere with us and old
women like loved our blow to they
thought it was so funny they're like oh
she's beautiful they'd like pinch her
cheek I swear to God it was like such a
hit this show is sponsored by better
heal I love the holidays but the
holidays can bring about a lot of extra
feelings it is a lot even just
Thanksgiving I went back for six days
and it's like I regress to like the
worst version of myself it's so hard to
really keep up and therapy is what I've
been doing T theapy it's like you're on
vacation but you can still do it this is
why I love better help it's designed to
be convenient it's designed for someone
like me who sometimes has really bad
days I can't get out of bed and
sometimes I just need I only have the
energy to turn on my phone and talk to
somebody I don't have to go drive
somewhere find parking they have this
great Journal feature where I can write
my thoughts and feelings in between my
sessions and all you have to do is you
fill out the simple questionnaire online
they'll match you with a licensed
therapist it's very easy it's very
convenient personally like pregnancy
I've been going through a lot of changes
having someone to talk those things
through with that's not just a friend or
a family member has been extremely
helpful for me um and in the season of
giving give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com Tuesday
today to get 10% off your first month
that's better help
hp.com sltr Tuesday I wish I had a video
of this I was brushing my teeth with my
quip on the way over driving and
quipping I was driving and quipping
thank you Tesla this is so cute that is
adorable I need this one this is so good
so this is a collaboration that's brand
new for quip it's with the renowned
artist and innovator Shantel Martin
known for her bold inquisitive artwork
and diverse creative Ventures and the
inspiration behind the collection
Shantel Martin believes in living a
happy healthy and artistically rich life
me too values that quip Champions this
collection is designed to inspire you in
the same way every morning and night
shantel's iconic line art Graces two new
limited edition products the smart
rechargeable toothbrush which Annie has
there and the g mint dispenser and it
brings simple function and Beauty to
Everyday Oral Care this is so cute if
you go to getquip.com tr Tuesday right
now you'll get 20% off any electric
toothbrush and mint gum dispenser plus
listeners of the show will get an
exclusive 20% off discount on the
Shantel Martin collection bundle that's
20% off any electric toothbrush mint and
gum dispenser or the Shantel Martin
bundle at getquip.com sltr Tuesday spell
gq.com Tuesday quip the good habits
company guys we're going to do a quick
lightning round Q&A about controversial
Christmas things so number one is
artificial or real tree real real
artificial for allergies and so you can
reuse it every year
it's so fun going to get them though I
love picking them out that was like the
most fun and my family one time my dad
tied it not tight enough and it fell off
on the highway and we had to like pull
over it was like almost see mishaps turn
out to always be the most memorable
things it feels like we were I'm like is
my dad Chevy Chase it was like are we in
that sounds like a freaking movie um
I've had both artificial growing up and
by the time I got to the real stuff like
now the smell is very I am jealous of
the smell but you can always light a
candle that's just Pine right so I
thought my ex-boyfriend had a fake tree
cuz this was my other Jersey boyfriend
because they had a white tree but they
just got a real tree and sprayed it with
the white yeah a flog that was pretty
cute really pretty that is cute pretty
[__] cute that's very Kardashian I
feel like white I thought more white
trash then but FL trees get really messy
how long do you guys keep the tree up
past December 25th um up until um um
three kings I think three kings is like
January 7th which is like a Catholic
thing oh my family has ad so just as
long until some my mom remembered and
mine's like the opposite of that my it's
like my mom is just like probably the
next morning just like everything I wake
up on the 26 every I'm like where is it
all it's all already there is that like
depression where like it's just winter
now is that why they call it boxing day
no it's the UK oh it's not cuz like
families box it up cuz that's really F's
mom shows up takes Tre down this year
this year I'm going home the usually
when I go on long trips I go like the
15th so like you milk that pre Christmas
but this year I'm going right before
Christmas so I'm going to stay in the
spirit like up until new yearor chain
yourself to the tree like people do like
Mom you're not taking it and then she
can just like lift it up because it's
not attached I um I wanted to say about
me decorating my apartment I my fiance
is still in his 20s so we already we
always have Christmas lights up just as
regular decoration it's still dorm dorm
style but think we I saw there's a
Christmas tree place right across from
our house and I'm like we H it's right
there and I've been clean being clean so
it's like I think before I never had it
cuz I was like oh my God there's so much
clutter that is the one thing when you
called me the other day and you're like
I got to go I got to go clean I'm like
who are you it feels good it's like okay
can I I have nocturnal panic attacks as
well and what I what I realized recently
which is like such a breakthrough for me
is I would wake up like in a full sweat
spinning about something and the next
day I would be like trying to
investigate why am I a panicky person
why do I have anxiety like I would be
looking at it too like Broad and then
the other day it hit me it's like I'm
panicking about something specific so I
was like I'm panicking about like ticket
sales so that's an actionable step I can
take is I'll just so now every time
before I go to bed and every time I wake
up I just go oh I'll like just promote
what I need to promote tonight and I'll
promote it in the morning like I just
think about what I need to do and then
like whatever new thing pops up I'm just
going to look at it like item like it's
almost like I have an internal to-do
list that's just like clicking in and
because I'm not checking in before I go
to bed it's happening in the middle of
the night so I'm looking at my anxiety
now as like a pushing force rather than
a thing that I have that I'm crippled by
cleaning has helped me too where it's
like there I have this dread over me it
feels like everything in my life is an
extracurricular activity when my house
is messy like I have this like homework
I need to do which is clean my house and
I'm not doing it so I have that a little
bit with exercise too so I've just been
like when I have a minute I just clean I
just clean and I feel so much better and
well gets you in the mood to clean like
for me my favorite thing is like get a
coffee and I'm like this is like my
little clean companion and then it gets
me pumped up to do stuff that's I didn't
even think about having I mean maybe I
can work on that but I just you know
what it is I've just been trying to tell
myself like every time I don't want to
do something it's Brave to do the thing
I don't want to do right now just be
brave be brave be brave so I just like
do it and then like halfway through like
sometimes I'm talking on the phone with
people and stuff but it's like the same
as like when I sit down do work we were
talking about with David so about the
Pomodoro thing where it's like 25
minutes alarm goes off you get five
minutes to around 25 minutes of focus
time I never get past one pomodora I do
25 minutes and then I do like five years
off and then I come back but I realize
like it's actually embarrassing how much
I can get done in 25 minutes like I'm
procrastinating all the time it's like
if focused energy for 25 minutes I get
like I write like a novel yeah and so
that's the same with cleaning it's like
if I just focus and keep like next step
Next Step Next Step
I can clean my own house in like I think
that's a 40 minutes yeah I think that's
a what I do is like you I set myself up
I'll have a playlist ready I'll have a
drink that I enjoy idea that's a good
idea and then I'll just choose one thing
that I know I want to work on but
usually that one thing leads to the
second thing so it's like as long as I
keep my um goal small with the cleaning
yes instead of saying I got to do
everything today then I feel more like
incentivized I'm like wow this place is
let me just move to the bathroom and see
what can how much I can get done there
like a basic thing of even like if I'm
like I'm just going to put the shoes
away and then it's just like oh then
I'll do this then I'll and I did it at
night before I went to bed the other
night like I just wasn't like exhausted
so I was like oh I'll just like clean up
and then I woke up to a clean place it
was like insane a feeling clean sheets
clean Place tree up fireplace going C
it's such a great feeling yeah I'm
getting into that too I I I think like
the
nesting that's supposed to hit me is
like slowly I'm like
oh rather than sit here I should go
through my this whole cabinet and it has
made me think to myself like I've always
like small spaces but I'm like I would
never want to be in a space that's too
big where you couldn't clean it yourself
if you had to yeah 32 for life I always
say that no matter how much money I make
it's going to be a three bedroom um two
B never more than 2,000 square F feet I
want a lot of outdoor space but it's
never going to be more than 2,000t cuz I
just can't clean it I don't want it you
can come visit me and have a wing
because I feel very different I can't
wait to have a staff um by the way I
don't know if you guys saw but it was
announced that Kim Kardashian has around
a dozen Christmas trees in just her
bathroom I saw that I did see that um I
I don't hate on it because 2019 the year
before the pandemic my family thought I
was insane for buying three large
Christmas trees and I had one in every
single corner and then sure enough we
missed three Christmases after that I
was like see I was like I had for curse
I might have put a curse but I have a
question are there trees made out of all
of the hair she got lasered
off that's so pretty that's gorgeous
like should I get a tree of my own it
just seems like a huge commitment car
the mess don't put it under the heater
directly so it doesn't dry out you got
one thing to carry and I tell you
something I did the other day I'll say
it's Christmas related just because
Christmas has lists and this was about I
knocked something off my to-do list that
I had to do for a long time I had
ordered this package of
NAD um infusions which I don't know what
it is do you know what it is yeah of
course I mean I just Joe Rogan said he
did it and I had money and I was like
okay they had a deal and I just spent so
much money on it two years ago so I go
into to get and it's like an infusion
what does it do I mean it's supposed to
do a lot of things but it's supposed to
it's very regenerative yeah um have you
done it I've never done it because um
it's a slow slow infusion right you kind
of have to sit there how long you sit
there 2 hours an hour and was an hour
and a half but it but I'll tell you what
happened so some people so you can leave
it open some crazy people leave it open
and they kind of pace around the because
it feels like it's hard to explain it
feels like your body is squeezing and
burning on the inside you have to like
take a [__] this is why I feel anxious
thinking about it which is why I haven't
tried it you do I listen if the rich
people do it just like do you just feel
like have energy legs I feel absolutely
incredible right now and I'm going to go
on on Friday and do it again but so okay
so I walk into the place that I go to
the two nurses there's like a medical
assistant a nurse and they're like
getting it prepared their coffee machine
was broken so I'm like I'm going to go
grab a coffee do you guys want a coffee
the medical assistant's like they both
say no but I can see that the nurse
wants one and I go come on let me give
you buy you a coffee I bring her her
matcha and I go this is like so you
don't prick me too hard you know I'm
like be easy on me so I go in they have
me in like a special room they put the
injection in I'm laying there and I'm
like I have to keep like they have a
call button for the nurse I have to keep
like being like all right like open it
more close it more cuz it's just like
hard to bear but in the middle of it I
start to feel so nauseous right like and
my new Louis Vuitton purse is there I
reaged I want to talk about rebug and
okay you a new purse and I like and I
don't tell my business manager and um
just Kidd he gets alerts he gets alerts
on his phone how funny is that like in
the middle of the night he'll just be
like oh she's having a nocturnal panic
attack she's coping but but I I just I'm
doing the call button it's not working
and I just lean over I just throw up all
over and I almost got out of my purse
just like a little bit on the outside I
threw up all of my pills and I threw up
my micro do I was like that's I go
careful that's
masculine that's mushrooms and masculine
but um so as the the girl is coming in
to clean the medical assistant I go
should have gotten that coffee
[__] but they were very nice about it
and then they they have like an anti-
nause thing that I'll take next time but
that's what the guys will do like the
guys that are like all proud they'll
have it open it'll take 20 minutes
they'll run around the room they have
the anti nausea thing they like jump up
and down they just try to get through it
the reason that I'm I'm makes me anxious
to think about is cuz I don't even drink
coffee I don't like things that make me
feel revved up like at all so like the
idea of like it it it feels like a panic
attack I can't escape I think during
it's hard but right now I just feel
young I me I know feel I just feel like
a little pep in my step and and it was
great it was cool it was like hilarious
to throw up all over the floor of the
mall I mean it was all just cold too
there was like nothing else in my system
oh that's probably why well they said
that yeah it never makes sense like
wouldn't I have five have more in my
stomach I mean I believe nurses but I
wait tell us about the the purse oh I
decided I wanted like a bigger purse and
I was like even though these are kind of
basic I really want one this girl I sat
next to on the plane she was like it's
so sturdy it just has everything and
I've just been like ailia beding around
town with like a bunch of things in my
hand like just looking ridiculous
dropping things all the time so I was
like I need a big purse and I want to
carry around my notebook I have this
like vision of like having a notebook
that has all of my things in it cuz I've
always been trying to have separate
notebooks so I like have and it's just
there's it's an it's not so I want to
have like my journal my joke list my
to-do list my drawings everything in one
thing even like print so brave to be
willing to leave the house with your
Journal listen no I've lost them I leave
and where do you think I'm leaving them
it's The Comedy Store it's who cares
I've had like nightmares I've done it
I've done it it's happened so many times
I'm through it I've gone through it
already it's all my iow like I had my
Journal was like I I was like on iasa
like writing crazy [__] sometimes I
leave my journal open and then I'll walk
in the room and Dave is and I'm like no
I like run and he's just making fun of
me it's always something so embarrassing
I have had a very this is where gets
this is even more embarrassing because
this is in my last lost Journal I've
started doing a thing this is very woo
woo guys I don't care it's actually
really crazy in working and I no one
told me to do this I just started doing
it I've been writing to myself in my
journal going like dear guides dear help
like whatever I say different thing each
time like Dear Light or whatever like
what like light inside like subconscious
like what do I need to know today and
it's my subconscious is like writing
back it's likeing weird it's like not me
writing back but I've gotten all this
like advice from myself it's F it's
really weird speaking of journals sester
I was I saw this post um on Instagram
and it's basically this really cute
Journal between mom and daughter oh
and it's just you the mom gives it to
the daughter and says whatever questions
you have for me about the world and like
write it here and then so they share
this journal and the mom answers on the
next page and it's so cute like some of
the questions are like why why do I feel
like Danny is going to tell on me like
really basic things like and the mom
will be like you know like I know you're
frustrated with Dany but remember like
you know you no don't mean you don't
have to be mean you can it's just my mom
would be like because you're
did you ever read your I read my mom's
Journal once and it was like poems about
me being like her broken child I was
like you f I was like I'm about to write
about you oh I wanted so I got this on
rebag what's that I've never heard rebag
is like the same as like the real re or
whatever it's like so it's like I like I
think I'm supporting a fellow over a
spender I'm helping a sister out and and
I hope it's reciprocated when I have to
sell all my purses too but so it's like
cheaper but you can get them at
different so this was like excellent
It's like brand really cute yeah was way
cheaper it's a classic bag what's a
great um entry purse that I can get if
I'm not a purse girly don't even it just
whatever I don't have a single get
yourself a tote bag from Trader Joe's
stop okay that's what I have right now
don't do it it's a waste of money I do
but I'm I don't want to start it for
someone else okay so it's not I'll go
shopping with you no I we can go online
no there's a medium ground have her do a
rebag it's cool and then it's their
investment pieces they can go with their
swatches because I don't have a single
fancy Pur I think designer purchases I
had that one year where I you know went
a little stupid I think it's so dumb oh
my God I'm going to have to go her baby
designer
things I'm don't do it Annie I'll take
you we'll go I'll take you on an
internet ride own your purchases own
your moves because here's what I think
okay and this could be crazy when I wear
this I feel really good I feel happy I
feel good it like makes me feel and of
course we're all falling into this like
scam or whatever but I like the scam I'm
enjoying the scam yeah the scam like
Sparks Joy it's not a scam I feel high
Vibe when I wear it I feel good I get it
I feel that too but I'm still saying
don't start I don't want to pass this on
to anyone and whoever steals this is
going to get a lot of insights from my
guide wait speaking tell me to buy more
purses of that journal you know what I
heard Kim Kardashian say she does for
her kids which like sounds so
magnificent and I want to do it and I
hope I do she says that every single
year on her kid's birthday she she
writes them like a five-page letter just
like about all the things they're into
that year their nicknames like what are
they like eating and so then the kids
will have that when they're adults I'm
like that's so incredible but do you
think you like manipulate it a little
bit just change a couple things like
what just like to make them have a
different
memory I don't know I like that but I
also like whatever my brain has kept but
it was cute we found our like report
cards when we were little that's from
nursery school and it was cute it was
like with my twin brother was like
saying how I would like tie his shoes
for him and stuff it is super cute yeah
I would want to know that stuff
yeah o is this a gift I have got you
guys a present I'm ready for it okay so
I wanted to get you guys something you
wanted and I listened to you when you
asked me what my highlighter was so I
got you each one wait the eye shadow you
mean this is the ey Shadow and the
highlighter yeah oh my God oh my God
thank you so much oh my God Annie that
this it's Urban Decay so this is the one
you're wearing right now it's so pretty
it's so pretty oh my God so pretty thank
you I didn't know who were doing I just
figured last minute can I say that I did
have an idea but it was not executed and
I wanted to get both of you um a sits
bath like a portable one well you're
going to know after birth why does Annie
know well it's going to be for her
hemoroids already been through it I've
already been in it [__] bath for the
hemorrhoids and it's bath for um you
know if you give birth vaginally then
you'll need do you think when I have
kids I'm going to have like a leg up
because I've already had every problem
that a pregnant woman has had honest
naturally I think that you're not going
to notice labor at all you're going to
people are going to be like Annie I
swear the baby's half out of you're be
like are you sure wait a second if why
did these gifts come from Stella because
I needed her to get them for me this
okay so I didn't know that was an option
I paid for
it some question I had for you guys is
your takes on Christmas movies we asked
the audience to like what their favorite
ones were cuz we thought it is not a
Christmas movie it's not at all Home
Alone four which one were you in I don't
know the Remake I don't think it was a
sequel one I only like the one Esther
was in I have one line so you're really
taking aine I have no idea what my line
was oh my God my ex-husband would freak
out if he knew that but it was in the
remake on Disney plus it doesn't matter
and my it was during Co and my scene was
with uh Kenan Thompson and Ellie keer
but Kenan wasn't there so like I never
got to meet Keenan he was just I met him
did I tell you how I met him I forget it
was my proposal night he was backstage
at Chris Angel with me is there anything
funnier in the world that so weird but
so I didn't even meet him but he was it
was I literally acting in the scene with
and he's not there so funny yeah I
actually don't I'm not a big Christmas
movie gir I wasn't either I wasn't
either but then my ex like it's all him
and his family did and then I've met
other people that are huge Christmas
movie people I feel like n die hard for
sure is a very popular one I know Home
Alone yes but I mean like all of the
good ones like Christmas Vacation like
that's that is like with Randy Quaid
like come on does Planes Trains and
Automobiles count wasn't that during
snowy that's Thanksgiving oh was
Thanksgiving that's Thanksgiving I okay
I loved I did love Home Alone um Love
Actually is insane I loved it when I
first saw it and then I watched again I
was like what was happening why tell me
what every it's just very weird it's
just a weird movie it's like there's a
Tik Tok Trend going around about how
problematic it's just weird it's like
the guy's like stalking one guy is like
stalking kir the best friend it's
psychotic like he's the videographer and
he doesn't film anyone but her he Zooms
in on her it's like it's very stalkery
it's weird it's like this isn't okay and
that's your best friend it's like ew the
Prime Minister also dating his yes and
and it's just like I don't know it just
doesn't seem like positive healthy
relationships this out and replace it
with a holiday with Cameron Diaz and
Kate Winslet Jack Black I do love that's
a great movie so one of the questions I
have Christmases even is the romcom the
best version I believe it is of the
Christmas movie so that's like the
holiday Sleepless in Seattle Family
Stone I don't think so I think the elves
Christmas vacation I think comedy is elf
elf is so good elf is the best the best
I do think we're like starred for an
absolutely hilarious Christmas movie
okay I do have a friend that's writing
one I just saw the best movie I've seen
in a million years and it is kind of a
Christmas movie like it is in Vibes but
not in content can I guess what did it
just come out yeah I saw it in the
theaters is it Godzilla minus one are
you joking no is Thanksgiving withan
what are you no cuz everyone's talking
about Godzilla minus
one amazing I did hear it's good and I
do want to see it okay you guys has
anyone here seen the holdovers no I've
not even heard of it oh my God it's the
best movie I se why are you holding this
over me like I am I am it's like it's
what is it it's going to have Oscar buzz
I'm pretty sure and it's directed by
Alexander Payne who directs really like
amazing movies like sideways my one of
my favorite movies all sideway no
election that's his movie and it's like
the performances he gets they're like so
so it's it's Paul Giamatti and it's like
sad and Christmasy and basically he's
this this like kind of grumpy teacher at
a an all boys like boarding school he's
a good Grump and it's called I know and
it's called the holdovers because it's
like he gets assigned to watch over the
kids that don't have families that have
to stay for Christmas Christmas break
so good you would you say you're like a
hot female PA yes I would I actually
would yes oh that does sound really good
you guys have to go see it and it's and
it's so awesome that it like has those
warm fuzzy holiday snow Christmas stuff
like I've been trying to recruit
everyone to go see the boy and the Heron
with me and I've set it on TIG know any
of these movies I want to see Tim's
Thanksgiving movie as all the boy in the
Heron is ha Miyazaki and um it's
supposed it was supposed to be his last
um animated film but our Pats is voicing
it and a lot of the cast is pretty great
although I'm going to watch the one with
the subtitles I have a question if we do
end up going to the movies together are
you able to eat popcorn yeah okay I am
good and I'm smile I wouldn't even ask
you well you know that like that's the
only reason I go I it's the movie is so
second the popcorn in the movie is
everything that's magic that's romance
that's travel everything you're out
there getting from traveling the world
world I'm getting it right there in the
movie oh I so it's my favorite it is my
number one favorite food also I like
going with my dad to the movies it's
kind of like our thing cuz he has to
wear have I talked about this where he
has to wear the headphones because he
doesn't he's hard of hearing so he wears
the headphones but then he screams and
he says horrendous things like I can't
even speak them on here he screams them
so loud I'm like Dad and he's like oh
and he starts laughing and he's laughing
so loud there was an older woman once
who she in the middle it was a daytime
movie we would always go to like random
times and she like went to go get a
drink or food or the bathroom or
something but she accidentally went
through the exit and so just light like
shined in and my dad just goes like he
just it's just it's so [__] funny I
love old man's sounds he's so good and
it was like him like making fun of
another old so it's just like so funny
Esther I feel like you would like have
you been to look Cinemas where you don't
even have to leave your chair and you
order I don't like that as much we have
I pick what it's like my Dre I pick is
where like someone comes it's like they
have it's a chain that's what she
talking about right oh it's the same
thing yeah it's like where someone
brings you the food right and it's like
recliners yeah I like that I like that I
like I'll tell you why I don't like it
why because I should be punished for
having to refill the the bucket and I
should have to miss I should have to
miss and I also I like having to make
someone next to me tell me what I missed
it's cute it's part of the oh that is
cute cute I'm like I'm like tell me
everything that I missed like since I
was 5 years old I've been saying that to
people this conversation is getting me
even more amped for the holidays because
there's nothing better than going to the
movies on the holidays we would always
go to the movies on Christmas we would
do New Year's Eve my my parents and I
would do New Year's Eve D we'd go to PF
Changs and then go to uh double feature
so we'd pay for one and go to two and
like that's what we would do too yeah
yeah that's like the best memories I
want to do that this year so badly
that's so cute that a lot of your sweet
memories are with your mom and dad it's
kind of sad but it's not it's not no
it's not wait can I what if we what if
we go to a movie we try to sneak into
the other one but we we pay them at the
end sure for the movie so we're not bad
but we just tell them they pay well
nowadays nowadays it's like a sign
seating so you can't do that anyway out
here that is true but if we get kicked
out that's funny what do you get for oh
wait I have a eser thing I the place I
threw up at the floor okay the woman go
the girl at the counter goes and by the
way I did get in a little thing with
them in the beginning where I was like
trying not to pop off I was like I'm
really trying not to pop off right now
but they charged me ,000 like I just got
a while I was sitting there I just got a
charge for $1,000 I was like what the
hell's going on here and it was just a
mixup and they fixed it but I was like I
was like felt I like was like trying to
keep my top on the whole time and then
afterwards I was like sorry I'm really
trying to not pop off it's like I
shouldn't be like upset by circumstances
everything works out no, charge is a lot
of [__] money I like 500 emails talk
to like 20 people on the phone it was
just but it got where do I come in she
goes the one guy comes out and like it's
like you know I know who you are and I
was like oh cute and he starts talking
to me about Comedians and people that go
into the other comedians that go in
there and then the other girl was like
that I almost got in the fight was like
I know you from glowing
up isn't that so cute so cute that's so
cute and she's working at like the NAD
place that's so on brand for glowing up
really a lot Beauty girlies or people
that I know from the beauty space really
loved that podcast it's weirdly having
like a moment on Tik Tok where people
are talking about it like it's because a
lot of the product the skincare products
that have trended in the last year on
Tik Tok are all things that we like were
kind of the first people to talk about
so I'm what if we had a glowing up
episode let's I would die to have we
could also even have like a little
segment if we wanted to zoom her in
sometimes I would die to have Caroline
on she would kill it would be Miss start
saying I was like I haven't seen her
since glowing up she's so good wait I
want to ask you what drink do you get at
the
movies um I okay when I'm being bad I
get frozen Coke and Cherry Coke and I
layer it and I wait for I just slurp all
the juice out of it and I just I like
when it's just like hard ice at the
bottom when I've gotten all the flavor
out and then Cherry Coke I like regular
Cherry Coke and then sometimes I just do
water cuz sometimes it's just over
yeah you get candy right now no but I
would definitely if I was feeling not
acid reflux I would do like a Sour Patch
watermelon I would do a cherry icy but
Dave got the weird okay so you know some
theaters now have those drink machines
where it's like a vending you press the
buttons Dave was like so proud of this
combo he made and I was so gagged by it
it's h he made half Sprite half grape
Powerade I'm interested
smilly European I don't know I was like
Dave well great powered does not have
bubbles in it right I was also like Dave
you're 45 like come on this is his
Christmas he's not going to celebrate
let him have his this is his Santa Claus
but I like the idea that you can mix and
match now they're giving us a lot of
power maybe I'm just hating cuz I can't
really have it I know I used to like I
used to really enjoy the boundary of you
can have Coke Diet Coke Cherry c someone
else has to do it for you the boundary
you call that a boundary well my only
boundary growing up dead serious was
when McDonald's stop like stopped
breakfast that was like the only time I
was told no as a child and when they
started letting I was like lost as a
person when they were like you can have
it all day so I was glad when they
whipped it back that was very confusing
time wait it's not all day anymore they
go back and forth It's like Taco Bell
taking away the potatoes and then
bringing them back we were talking about
this earlier like it I don't I don't
like it also just a great marketing it's
like the mcreb right wait what do you
get at the movie theater um this is
going to absolutely blow your mind you
I'm going be absolutely hate the movies
I try not to go to the movies I've had a
lot of panic attacks at the movies and
um I try to I feel like Esther's kid on
Christmas yeah I know I know I don't
know what happened to me when I started
to become afraid of the idea like I feel
claustrophobic there is a sense of
anxiety in it but I do go um and um I am
really boring it's just
water I only drink water and and um I
sometimes reach over for popcorn so if
we go it's going to be great for you cuz
I will not steal your popor we're
getting your own buckets yeah I will you
can you can share my bucket cuz I will
be getting another one you have one paw
of Annie's bucket no you can listen no
I'll be generous with the first bucket
I'm not the second bucket back the up
actually at some points I go eat some of
the bucket I also though do want to
validate you a little bit cuz I get
claustrophobic too and I do need to come
forward and say I will only see a movie
if I get the exact seat that I want
which is the very last row on the aisle
what I will only sit there for any like
I will I don't want to go if I can't sit
okay I just want to say one of my
favorite scenes of any Final Destination
was in a movie theater and that's not a
good spot oh my God why it's hard to get
out when I can see when the place is
collapsing I mean it's Final Destination
so there was like things ping ping ping
why do you like that seat cuz I have
like a little bit of a claustrophobic
thing and
control that's fine and I also easy
Escape I also need to if I have to go to
the bathroom I don't want to step over
people like you guys well you're not
step you're the Tini you just go under
their legs I also need to like stretch
my leg where do you like to sit I like
to sit like Center like right like
wherever the handicap seats are It's
usually the one above is good because
it's like they do give I will say I like
that about the new theaters they always
give the handicap people like the best
special needs people the right there um
and then you can put your feet on their
head just
kidding no but can't do anything about
it what are they going to come get me um
I know it's all cocky to put your feet
up next to them like look what I can do
yeah I don't mind the going by people
again it's like I want to have to suffer
to get the popcorn I don't want it to be
too easy but I like the big cushy like
Rel like reclining ones now are really
cool I will say I went to a movie I went
and saw Ninja Turtles with my my nephews
and I was so pissed cuz I love to talk
during I like my Say by yourself cuz I'm
like no it was horrible it was sorry
Seth uh Rogan but my nephew was like I
love cuz I I like to Myster Science
Theater and just like talk the entire
time it's like fun to go with Comics if
like making jokes but my nephew was like
like he was watching was like and I was
like trying to poke him and be like hey
jam and he was just
like I was like oh my God the Ninja
Turtles stole my
nephew but yeah no I think it would be
funny if we went to the movie theaters
together and we each sat and different
completely different areas that's where
all the kids are fingering themselves up
there or fingering each other I think
that's why I don't like the movie
theaters cuz you Got Fingered there um
yeah so um when I was we haven't had one
of these stories in a while I know must
be
Christmas okay thank you for reminding
me of why perhaps I get scared in movie
theaters um I was 12 years old I was
dating a boy who was a lot older than me
I don't know how we were allowed hang
with each other thought but this was the
first time that he tried to both kiss me
and I was um I wasn't ready for it and
then I think he tried I didn't think he
tried to finger me and I the movie was
called The
Relic and I it was some horrible movie I
hardly remember I just know it was
called The Relic lik and I just got
finger blasted without wanting anything
okay first of all I'm very sorry so
that's why I drink water only water
hopefully he had a little butter on that
popcorn is this the Relic That's The
Relic oh my God is that what it look
like afterward sorry it did that's
exactly how my like I think I like The
Relic I'm very sorry than you and maybe
we could recreate a happy memory both
you finger me when you like it yeah oh
my God will you guys both finger me so
that memory is erased yes we'll put
we'll put a hole in the popcorn and
we'll somehow have it go through because
you know the yeah then I'm in for every
movie
you guys want to watch well Feliz
Navidad to both of you and to you thank
you Fel Navidad proud of you excited
this is EXC this is your last childless
well I guess you're Child full already
but last child in your arms hopefully
Christmas all goes well but yeah no I'm
I'm really excited and I hope everyone
all the slugs have a really fun
Christmas comment let us know what you
guys are up to do you open presents on
Christmas Eve or Christmas Day what are
you doing for Hanukkah whatever it is
that you celebrate or don't celebrate if
you're like Dave yeah I have a a
suggestion for comments below I I've
noticed that we have a lot of pregnant
slugs oh can you guys write what you're
going to do with your kids with Santa
Claus I think idea in the comments yes
and the slug pop Papas and also quick
pregnancy update this past so I'm like
23 24 weeks right now and this past week
was like the first week it's gotten
really consistent where I can feel
movement which has been a game Cher like
update for the pregnant fellow peges out
there because before that you just like
don't know if it's still there feel
because Whitney told you it was food too
so that got in your head maybe you don't
feel as connected to the pregnancy yet
now I like now I feel more connected and
also now it's just like good reassurance
like everything's working as it should
um so that's been like a really fun is
there a kicking or movement I don't know
cuz it's it's not like bam but it is
also like pop it just feels like
something is in your body and it's
popping now or moving or can see it's so
weird but it's I'm finding it to be like
I'm like cuz I'm really trying to point
out the positive experiences of this
time and so I'm like okay that's like
something I look forward to every night
is like laying down and kind of feeling
that cuz they come out they come out at
night are you noticing that people are
like specifically men I always ask wom
in this treating you differently like
open no because I'm not going out in the
world looking pregnant like I wear
baggie clothes and stuff so but I'm
excited for that she's going full Teen
Mom yeah hiding it yeah anyways slugs
Merry Christmas we hope you guys have a
great holiday season and we'll see you
next week with a brand new episode BL
you guys we love you grateful for
[Music]
you